Oh everybody welcome to the 2018 Reason
magazine editorial juggernauts webathon
telethon is that what we're calling it
now webisode it's just a weapon no but
this is this thing this is a live
podcast live podcast we're live podcast
so this is the reason editors around
table special edition we usually do this
on Monday so go there on Apple podcast
and Spotify and subscribe to it all on
but we're doing it especially on
Wednesday of this week in conjunction
with the reason
weboth on our 11th annual attempt and
and a pleasurable week having of asking
you our favorite people in the universe
to give us your tax-deductible donations
to make all of our journalism and
commentary possible out there we want to
welcome everybody out there whether
you're watching on YouTube or Facebook
or at reason itself whether you're
libertarian or not whether you're
struggling with your faith
please enjoy us and and all throughout
this live video cast streaming thing
that we're doing send us questions the
mechanisms by which you can send those
questions or add an email address that I
don't have in front of me and also by
comments on the blog post that we have a
recent calm right now and on our twitter
feed and on etc i'm joined as we always
are or usually are on the reason editor
to a podcast like Katherine mega Ward
editor-in-chief of everything reason hi
Nick Gillespie some guy we found on the
street and you're Superman cheers
managing editor a reason that comeback
nick has been off the street and and
high on reason for more than 25 years
that is correct that's a 25 plus it
started in October of 93 so it's you and
Bob Poole at this point are kind of the
longest tenured we know there's also
Jacob solemn has a discontinuous record
that's longer because he was here first
but then left and then came back yes I
did briefly to a higher plane of
consciousness and then rejoined us here
on the music alliterative headlines even
in 1910 writer in history yeah no not
true you just wrote really high-quality
90s headlines headlines are just about
there
why the past tense yeah he doesn't write
headlines anymore so and then also
Barbara actually our former art director
who now is helps out with certain
elements also predates me by at least a
couple months that's amazing
so saying is we've all been around
forever and you should pay our salaries
not exactly that but we're gonna get to
that in a second you can contribute to
the payment of our salaries and our
booze habit so to go and give to us
again tax-deductible donations could be
it could be in cash it can be in crypto
currencies go to reason.com slash
webathon and if you're writing about any
of this right now on a social media
platform do little hashtag buddy and
then webathon 2018 at around the
commencement of this particular
broadcast and this is day two we've been
doing this for a little over 24 hours
um two great posts from Nick and
Katherine already on this although
tomorrow
I knew this minute you said something
nice about our without us I was like
he's gonna say it's not that's not about
me it's just about the found material
that we have I'm not going to spoil it
however I so from this time so we're
doing a week-long webathon we've had
about 200 donors I see here which is an
incredible number I think in fact it's
even more than maybe the first webathon
that we did 11 years ago and a total of
around 36,000 dollars in donations thank
you
that's amazing let's see about making
those numbers legit over the next 60 to
90 minutes or however long we are here
you think we double it or else I'm going
full Buddhist monk okay I mean I thought
the bagan thing was gonna go quietly
meditate I'm just gonna pour my gasoline
over my head to light myself on fire so
you're gonna go have s'mores this
afternoon anyway in the office that's
true I wish we had office Morris yeah ah
at sure that's against the fire code of
some sort at any rate there is a
matching donation system that's also
still available to us right now I'm
going to read this off of a teleprompter
known as my computer because these are
sometimes difficult to describe
one recent donor has agreed to match the
first $25,000 in gifts from during this
telethon telephone from people who have
never given before to reason over our
last 11 years of doing this and also
just in the history of reason um or who
increase their giving if they increase
their giving another donor will match
that increase from last year's total by
another $25,000 and I'm pretty sure none
of that makes sense the way that I just
talked about it but that's not the fault
of the person who wrote this let's go to
questions because we have a lot of them
and I'm already tired of hearing myself
talk this is a good way to actually
start off tawny flirty from Facebook and
sorry for mispronouncing your last name
or end your first name
why does reason need to beg for
donations Katherine a business shouldn't
be in business if they don't have a
profitable business model begging for
money isn't a sound business model
just a thought I love the flora magazine
called reason this is a very reasonable
question it's a strong place for us to
start so two things first reason is
published by a non-profit has been since
1978
and you may have noticed that lots of
other journalistic outlets are just now
getting up in that game because we are
totally ahead of every single curve is
that not true
pretty much nothing or even the begging
curve especially the making curve and
and journalism that is published by
nonprofits has a lot of advantages and
one of them is that we are not beholden
to advertisers we are not beholden to to
anyone really because so many people
give us money that we we get a lot of
freedom and flexibility out of that so
thank you for your donations and thank
you for your question and not all
businesses are justified by their
profits as even I rant would remind us
and also these are parts of our revenue
model itself too I would add to a
captain just said that the number the
total number of donations actually makes
us more flexible there's no single
person on this earth who if they totally
change their mind about reason tomorrow
or keeled over or whatever any calamity
can happen there's no a single person on
which reasons existence depends with the
exception of possibly NYX or Bob pools
to to be a frank about it however that's
because we have this diverse Y portfolio
opinion journals and magazines of
opinion journalism they all either have
a rich benefactor who when they get
bored of losing money suddenly changed
their mind and then the magazine goes
pro quacky
or they have a non-profit model or they
just lose money hand-over-fist I would
just invite people to look at the modern
history of the new republic to see what
it's like to not have a stable nonprofit
model let's go to a question for Peter
Sudirman from Brent Cordner
of Twitter says should libertarians be
in favor and he spelled that with a you
got a Brit up in here but that's
Canadian even worse of universal health
care when it is not achievable via an
unregulated market Peter so I have
written in the New York Times no less
that in fact what we need in America is
a party that says in that we don't need
guaranteed comprehensive coverage by the
government and so if that's what you
mean by universal health care I think my
answer is no if what you mean by
universal health care is the maximum
number of people with easy affordable
access to health care I think
libertarians can and should be in favor
of that there are different systems that
you could design and think of that that
might that might get us there the system
we have is not that any additions from
our other crowd here oh I mean isn't it
kind of is there any reason Peter to
think that health care would be
different than food ultimately that a
free-market
you know relatively unregulated or
lightly regulated ends up throwing off
enough wealth as well as enough
different stuff where health care is
opposed to having health insurance or
having a gold-plated health insurance
plan virtually everybody would be taken
care of and certainly not everybody in
Canada goes to the doctor when I need to
if your question is is there any reason
the answer is yes and that would
basically be arrows theorem named after
the economist
Kenneth arrow who made a quite
popular influential argument that
healthcare is fundamentally different
from all other market goods and so this
is kind of the big tension in a lot of
thinking and arguments about health care
is that people who sort of think it
should be part of the market basically
think well that that it works basically
like food that it works you know not too
different from from food or from housing
or from automobiles and housing and
automobiles also have subsidies attached
to them but that the market basically
that people can be informed consumers
and arrows argument was you cannot be an
informed and intelligent consumer about
healthcare because of two things
one is you don't know your own condition
and two is the treatments are too
complicated I'd think that there is I
think that that it is not an entirely
fallacious argument on the other hand it
goes he and a lot of folks have taken it
way too far and you can have market
mechanisms spring up to take care of the
information a spring up though
in the market in the extremely regulated
almost entirely government dominated
even where it's theoretically nominally
private system that we have right now
and you can have charity too right so
like when when accidents befall you and
suddenly you go to the doctor and your
headache requires four expensive
treatments in 36 hours and an ambulance
ride by the yes driver hypothetically
you're not priced shopping but in a
system where you know you're a waif back
when stuff wasn't crowded out you'd have
a charity hospital so I mean you know
the kind of the ideal model that a lot
of folks talk about who are sort of who
are more market oriented is that you buy
health insurance when you're young when
you get out of college when you are in
college when you're in high school even
when you when you be when you earn it
when you become an adult at pre before
you find out what's going to happen to
you in the rest of the rest of your life
so before the insurance company
restaurants right if you're working at a
fish restaurant in Florida with a bunch
of alligators and maybe you have to get
the alligator writer I don't know but
this so this is how it works well the
writer is another great job
actually I mean in fact the fish
restaurant that I worked at had an
alligator Wrangler but let's talk about
let's get back to the health care part
the thing the idea is that you buy it
when you're when you're well and when
the insurance would be cheap and then
you keep that plan through the rest of
your life and perhaps even by a
guarantee that is like an ad on these
there's some research suggesting that
these would be quite inexpensive that
you basically you buy your insurance and
then you buy an additional sort of
top-up guarantee that says they can't
raise your rates and you do that when
you're twenty two or twenty five and you
keep that insurance unless you get a
better deal because people would compete
in this market rather than the crazy job
attached health insurance market that we
have right now you keep that insurance
for the rest of your life
keep paying these sort of like keep
paying that low rate or a rate that
Rises at some sort of pre negotiated
reasonable amount and what this does is
it detaches health insurance from
employment it makes it portable and it
means that that everybody's that
everybody has a reasonable incentive to
pay into the system without say a
mandate which we don't we sort of don't
have anymore
let's move to a question that I want to
throw it Nick here from Carlos Diablo
hit-and-run common term it seems to be a
standard reason dog went out to feel
that border should be completely open
and unchecked
do you feel that this is a radical
notion and do you feel that this should
at all be tempered given the
complication for this implemented by the
ever-growing social safety you know one
of the I think the biggest problems that
we have been talking about immigration
policy is that the use of the term open
borders meaning the idea that there are
no borders or there are no checkpoints
there's no vetting of anybody done I
think what I know when I write about
open borders or invoke it and I suspect
people you know you know the rest of you
as well what it means is that you go to
a checkpoint and you present
identification and there's a background
check on you to see if you have
communicable diseases or a criminal
record or fleeing from someplace
if
you don't I think the presumption should
be that you're allowed to come to this
country live legally for as long as you
want work etc that's that's what open
borders means to me so it's not willing
away the idea of borders for all sorts
of reasons but and also most people like
you know you land at an airport you're
gonna you know you're already at a place
where you're gonna be checked one way or
the other you crossed borders on roads
that have checkpoints and things like
that but what did the social safety net
aspect of it so I come in past the anal
probe at the border and now I want to
get others know but it you know if if
there is a tension between immigration
having more immigration and a safety net
I think we should be working to minimize
the safety net first and foremost but
then when you look at most analyses that
look at the aggregate effects of
immigration whether it's legal or
illegal and illegal immigrants by the
way are at a ten-year low in the country
it's been declining for for a decade now
and continues to look like it's gonna be
sloping downward but they end up being a
net benefit to the economy both in terms
of the amount of taxes they pay in
overtime versus what they take out the
amount of criminality the amount of
economic growth they bring so that if we
want to talk about economic effects even
people economists who are hostile to
more immigration grant that immigration
unmet as an economic good then there
were questions about cultural issues
which are I think a different kind of
topic that we could discuss well I also
think I mean open borders is the same
thing now as saying someone who's
pro-choice or pro-life right it's a it's
a shorthand that does a disservice to
the subtleties of the debate so when
people say reason is open borders it's
the same thing as saying reason is
pro-choice which is to say actually
virtually everyone that reason has their
own place where they draw and parse
lines and also anyway nobody is
genuinely advocating a full-fledged like
utopian version of open borders anywhere
in our
functional political system right like
the thing you described it sounds great
to me but it doesn't matter at all
because we are so far from that we are
like a million million miles from that
we are as long as the caravan marched
from that and and while it's of course
good to keep goals and long term ideas
in mind like what's actually on the
table right now is should we
dramatically reduce legal immigration
which is what is currently happening
right and also crackdown on illegal
immigration explicitly using family ties
as a lever and and employer sanctions or
should we like maybe at least not go
backwards on this question right like
that's where reason is actually it you
know it's it's an odd thing though too
because two years into Trump's
presidents here a little bit less than
that support for immigration of
according to public surveys and went on
are at all-time high so according to Pew
Gallup seventy-five percent of Americans
now agree with the with the statement
immigration is good for the country yeah
that's probably a big part of it
sixty-five percent of self-identified
Republicans eighty five percent of
self-identified Democrats but these are
historic eyes in America going back to
the other colonial period had a vexed an
ambivalent relationship towards
immigration but I think you know most
Americans agree that immigration is good
most people dislike the idea of illegal
immigration because of the illegal thing
and the way to fix that is by making it
easier to come here legally a quick
lightning round from Maggie over to hit
and run and Sudirman you can't take more
than one minute to do this what's
everyone drinking Superman gets two
minutes this is easy I'm drinking a left
hand which is a boulevardier with Molly
bitters that was pretty quick really I'm
drinking a period also with his left
hand no I am drinking whatever bourbon
was in reasons booze cabinet and yes
reason has a booze cabinet and yes
there's a lot of turnover and I'm
drinking whatever white wine was in
reasons a booze fridge which usually is
a bit dicey but that's pretty good yeah
it's meeting the Welsh
wife standard yes it is another quick
lightning round here which maybe I'll
start with David Weinke and I sounds I
definitely mispronounced that sounds
like I did but it is pretty phonetic I
think history will judge me kindly from
YouTube that's got to be a misspell do
you think David is gonna judge you
kindly that's not it's really this is
like Ralph but nurse good play good name
there's there's a missing ballad oh my
god do I miss Ralph anushka i curious
what everyone's born again moment was to
libertarianism the who what where when
and how it happened in fact I won't go
first cuz Nick has a better story Nick
one yeah yeah actually I don't have a
particularly good story but I started
reading reason in high school my brother
went to college and found it in the
college bookstore and started sending it
back to me and so I started reading it
and I was like wow that makes a lot of
sense around the same time I discovered
free to choose by Milton and Rose
Friedman I was like oh that kind of
makes sense and then it kind of went
into a latency period like a retrovirus
and when I went to grad school in the
late eighties at the pretty much no it
was the the trigger the HIV was
political correctness it was a you know
it was really in the late 80s was the
really particularly after and I've been
thinking a lot about this what happened
because the professorial and the Academy
is much more left-wing than it used to
be I mean it's always been kind of
liberal or leaning to the left but I
think it was when Mike Dukakis lost to
George HW Bush people lost their [ __ ] in
in the academies and universities and
they felt like for the first time that
they were forever going to be the
prisoner of a kind of Reagan America and
that's when they really got super
politicized and things really became
super ideological and as a result of
that I started thinking about okay well
where am I on this and that's where the
libertarian like a smaller libertarian
classical liberal 19th century you know
coming out of the 19th century and
earlier belief in kind of partial
knowledge
lura lism tolerance tolerance tolerance
and whatnot and it melded perfectly with
the post-modernism you know that I was
actually kind of being inundated with in
in the Academy at that point I told you
people then they could have the best
answer this and I was correct although I
don't want to sell short soon soon
what's your there was no one moment but
there were a couple of first exposures
and the very very first exposure I would
let the disease metaphor go you guys
casis model works of course right it was
the first time the first aliens like the
libertarian aliens landed in my life was
when I was working at a books-a-million
in in Destin Florida and books-a-million
had one of their selling points was that
they had the best magazine rack of the
best and by best I mean the biggest and
my sort of biggest selection of
magazines of any of the major chain
bookstores in the country and of course
you work at a place like this in the
sort of winter spring season when
there's nothing big coming out and you
are out of time to let you didn't have
any customer I mean it was B right like
you the beach reads are a thing and you
still have bookstores at the beach but
they they sell during you know stars at
the beach last time I checked I mean not
literally
and so I particularly noticed though we
know where you live that 2004 that was
sent to subscribers show with an image
of their house on the on the cover
custom printed for them and so that was
sort of like point one and then later I
was reading I became sort of more
interested in kind of political
journalism and opinion journalism when I
read a lot of conservatives basically
arguing with libertarians and ended up
thinking that the libertarians were
right and also at that time spent a fair
amount of time this was when Wikipedia
was relatively new spent a fair amount
of time just like reading through the
the kind of the chain of stuff that you
that you encounter when you just
Wikipedia libertarians and so all the
kind of relevant thinkers you know sort
of who have influenced a lot of
free-market types on the the right
broadly construed
sort of went through and sort of figured
out what they were
and then started actually reading their
books and it was as I wrote you know we
all did our origin stories for the 50th
issue there was no moment where I where
I changed what happened was I realized
that fundamentally this was who I was
and it wasn't it wasn't a moment of like
oh now I'm a libertarian I wasn't before
it's wait that's what I've always been
that's a bit like that for me too
Kathryn ayan Rand the end it usually did
begin and I was 15 I read a bunch of Ayn
Rand I was raised by nice DC good
government liberals who tried to save me
for the good cause and then they made a
mistake my mom gave me a copy of The
Fountainhead Oh which yeah oh yeah my
regrets there yeah so you know she for
her it was a book about architecture and
she thought it was a cool book about art
and architecture and I was like this is
my new life shape and then there was a
pretty rough summer there where I was
probably not great to live with because
because I like secondhand der's who
should be treated badly or something and
were you calling your parents moochers
and looters like my dog their whole
business why didn't the Fountainhead
create more architects well I mean I do
I actually do think The Fountainhead is
partially responsible for the fact that
in Hollywood when they want someone to
have a profession that's like cool and
artistic but not like you know totally
artsy first it's always mr. Brady
mr. Brady was everything exactly so I
actually do think that's true able to I
enter and if I had to guess but anyway
then I went to college and read some
other books and discovered that there
was maybe a broader term that I could
have lied to myself I sort of looked
more like Peters historia on some level
I was brought up as a just
anti-communism was in the air my dad
worked in the defense industry my
stepfather
introduced me to Robert Heinlein
speaking of a teenage books back in the
day which I thought was pretty cool
because there's a lot of naked ladies
and shooting stuff and still not wrong
about any of that and I think I wrote my
my high school thesis paper was a
mash-up of how Robert Heinlein stranger
to strange land influenced and and was
sometimes used as a blueprint of while
predicting the Summer of Love in 1967
which then it do you have a copy of that
I do can't call the Martian and the
hippies can we publish it it's not good
we did publish a version of that no yeah
it was I of that thesis not of your
piece but okay thesis that Heinlein is
particularly fascinating because he
spoke to you know both kind of like cold
war hawks and hippies which like he's
his early stuff is just shoot him up and
super yeah whatever called his juveniles
and stuff like Starship Troopers and
whatnot in for a treat holder I mean
suddenly it's time enough for love and
wow it's always time and there's always
time enough for Lyme and it's like jello
not time for anything else yeah it's
early on in in hate crimes but then I I
lived in Eastern Europe for eight years
drank sudirman and and then exposed me
to seeing what the post communism was
like which was terrible and came back to
this country expecting that we had had
had some kind of Truth and
Reconciliation community commissions
where you know Bill Kristol or William F
Buckley on one side and and you know
Ralph Nader on the other oh that's a bad
example but I would sit around so you
know what we kind of we shouldn't really
have supported the Contras so much maybe
we were wrong about South Africa like
all this would have taken place while I
was gone cuz I didn't know because you
didn't have the internet over there and
I came back in America was even more
dumb than ever and uh and there in the
middle of the impeachments as we called
them right then that's uh that's when I
came back and so I looked around for my
god is there anybody here who is sane
talking about politics and that's when I
discovered both Virginia post rels in
person on her case she sought me out and
to buy me lunch which is very nice
because I don't have any money
and then also Nicholas peas reason them
but oh my god this makes sense to me
so when did you come back in nineteen
eighty eight gone like
in March so like we were in Cuba
Emmanuelle was my wife was in Cuba
covering the Pope's historic visit to
Cuba and then the entire world's
journalistic or left two-thirds of the
way through that trip because of monell
Monica Lewinsky and ma'am the Pope and
Castro were just passed sure so what
we've got here is an r and robert
heinlein free speech and the internet
basically yeah that's all so that's the
that is the TLDR version of how you
became a libertarian yeah let's follow
up on that from my james adams from
youtube and just to remind everybody
we're here doing a web thought as i
mentioned at the top we've got what the
36,000 donors a thousand dollars $200
thousand donors but each of them only
gave us one dollar you need to give us
more dollars no i'd like to see more
numbers those are you watching if you're
enjoying this or even if you're doing it
out of a sense of spite doesn't matter
doesn't matter please Matt loves numbers
it's about hang about it calm people
love numbers Peter no statistics right
numbers are beautiful numbers are poetry
nice Amber's are green I still do like a
Roger Angela boxscore he's all
highfalutin I well it's got a number in
it does it which one I was going to a
different questions what CD you made me
now look in process oh this is not where
I was gonna go with but since she's the
boss
dean love from Twitter yeah that's your
name what does America feel like when
our debts carrying cost hit one trillion
dollars per year Katherine it feels bad
it makes me feel uncomfortable I don't
feel great about it by carrying cost
he's talking about interest there yeah
this is so this is the money that it
costs us to oh all the money we owe
which is and yep I mean it's coming
right like these numbers accelerate so
fast that sometimes these days I make
you know so every journalist fears
making the million billion mistake where
you you just miss type and it's like
accidentally in order - [ __ ] off but I
now I'm making like
million trillion mistake sometimes like
that's where we are in numbers about the
government and how much freakin money it
owes yeah it's I mean the the carrying
cost alone is I believe either already
or very very nearly more than we are
paying annually from Medicaid which is
one of the largest programs of social
insurance programs of any kind in the
country
and the person who actually I would say
so far has the best explanation of this
is my gal novelist Lionel Shriver who
has written a novel about the life in
Brooklyn when this particular apocalypse
happens that's interesting we have a
lightning round having to do the hair
what's wrong with you people
what's right with you people will start
obviously with Nick here from Nicki
palasa that's a shocker to Nick what is
your secret for luscious hair genetics
yep I think pretty much that's it it's
the only inheritance I got along with a
Tupperware mixing bowl that we I don't
know did you guys grow up with vomit
bowls like when you were sick your
parents what we call the toilet you can
take that back but you can sleep in the
water closet it's the hair and the
Tupperware vomit tell this is from a
delta 900 from youtube tells Sudirman
the beard looks awesome did he join the
shave club I did not join a shave club I
did try one of those like dollar razor
situations a couple years ago from the
internet and it was not good the razors
like they were very slippery in your
hand and I was like that I'm gonna I'm
gonna kill myself
no I just got more I got into my late
30s and like I crossed the rubicon past
35 and I was like I need it it needs to
be different the whole things need to be
different what do you mean wait are you
talking about razor quality no no me the
hair the hair meet the me I mean it was
getting different but maybe not in the
way that also there was a pocket square
situation happened around the same time
would you say and he finally weaned
himself off microwave pizzas right
around the same well you know there's
some laughs in the way that like
president
Obama quit smoking yeah so not Catherine
from this is Brianna anak and sorry from
history on so your name from YouTube
Catherine's hair is amazing is a simple
scent it's not a question truth not
wrong not genetics not wrong and anyone
who criticizes although the things took
crisper right maybe like you could could
you know that you're asking is my hair
no no we're technology no we couldn't
yes genetically engineered purple haired
babies serenade our life there's just
there were just now we have in theory a
pair of twins in China
Lulu Inanna who are Christopher babies
and I I personally am looking forward to
as Ron Bailey says having more kids when
I'm older who I will like create using
CRISPR and they love purple air you just
freaked me out the question to me from
FN Bob from Twitter who cut Matt Welch's
hair that's an important question um
I there's a so you don't want to go it's
a place called the blue and black I
believe not black and blue black on
Court Street in Brooklyn and I recommend
it not necessary because the cut but
because they serve II a beer and they
play really good like punk rock music
didn't you used to go to a place here
that had like it was like some kind of a
sily rennet or something like that down
the street that's an it's a Washington
institution oh sorry
Washington is like what does face Plaza
down there I mean that's the app that's
his face Plaza yeah I mean is it called
that little this tree they've got eight
by tens of every you know Supreme Court
and to justice in history it's all
phenomenal um let's try to bait Nick
more on immigration yeah uh here got
fish YouTube for neck Nick you had done
a video on immigration and specifically
border control concerning what happened
over the Thanksgiving weekend have your
thoughts changed about immigration and
border security no and it's I mean here
to me the weirdest thing about that the
discourse about immigration is like so
you have a couple hundred people who are
storming the border and you know it's
true that
there have been in every year going back
10 years there have been hundreds of of
kind of instances where border border
control actually does use pepper spray
or like has to restrain people from
crossing the border but I mean for God's
sake like if we can't handle a couple of
hundred you know migrants trying to
flood the zone I don't you know what do
we got going on I think again you know
the the larger question is like do we
want to process people in a way that is
fair and equitable and makes sense and
you know we should be doing more of that
but I don't see that I did the whole
Caravan stuff is a great example I think
of where Donald Trump has been really
good at kind of stoking anxiety about I
mean it really is just kind of this
cloud of dust it's almost like the
people who are who are chasing after
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
they're always way off in the horizon
and they're always you know kicking up
you know my god you know they're coming
they're coming closer they're coming
closer and it's like by the time they
get here it'll be a couple of hundred
people down from from a few thousand we
have what three hundred and thirty
million people in the country I think we
can handle it recent comback slash
webathon go there please donate and on
social medias a hashtag webathon 2018 in
case you are flinging rhetorical feces
at us here is a question from Twitter
and for Mina or Mina sorry to Matt Welch
what low-hanging fruit slash policy
improvements do you all think are
reasonable to expect to be implemented
in the next five to ten years reasonable
to expect as is loaded but I would
imagine the next five ten years we're
gonna see even the next five to ten days
maybe if things go in the right
direction we're gonna see a continuation
of what we've seen since Colorado in
Washington 2012 which is the dismantling
of all the various pieces the drug war
fact this morning in its own way there
was a look like a dismantling of a
little piece of the drug war in the
Supreme Court oral arguments right yeah
an argument about civil asset forfeiture
which
to do with drugs it has everything to do
with drugs like a lot of terrible things
or when the Supreme Court started
looking at and excusing these kinds
civil asset forfeiture is when the cops
say this computer was was involved in a
drug transaction I'm going to take it
even though I'm not charging Katherine
with a crime um and then I'm going to
take it and I'm going to auction it off
or just steal it why are you turning
away from me I want to look and I'm
going to keep the money to fund my
operations it's like crazy they're
stealing from you there's no other way
around that but in the beginning in the
early 19th and often you don't even have
to be convicted you don't have been
charged yeah there's just because they
think they sort of tagged you as as
being involved in something go back and
look at the argumentation for doing that
in the early 1970s it was about two
things about the mafia and he was about
drugs and it was also about the drug
mafia in the Supreme Court cases
themselves that they believe is William
Rehnquist wrote the majority opinion in
in the relevant case which I can't cite
I've taught my head in which he
basically said yeah I know this looks
really kind of crazy
what would the whole Fourth Amendment
and anything but you know trouble times
called for troubled solutions terrible
so it's all I feel super-confident
that's a sight right that I look in the
vol conspiracy it's I'm just block
quoting myself here um but no it was all
about drugs and so we're gonna see lots
of little things like this today just in
case no one knows I'm talking about
there was a civil asset forfeiture case
involving the state of Indiana doing
some terrible thing and Neal Gorsuch
said to the Solicitor General I believe
of Indiana again this is a SuperDrive
ah like bro are you even kidding me what
are you talking about what you thinking
about um that seems more like a Kavanagh
a lie Oh too soon good um so yes we're
gonna see a lot more of this we're gonna
see more states legalize we finally got
illegal marijuana on the shop on the
East Coast I never thought I'd see that
happened terrible coast on the east and
and there's so much like on in Florida
of all places on Election Day they are
Ian's franchised of ex felons who for
decades have not been allowed to vote
these are all little tiny little bits
the drug war next five to ten years I
think that's going to be the
but are there other things in the next
five to ten years that you either expect
or think or think that if we sort of
push maybe the wall will come here
here's this is a small one but I think
it's significant and ties into something
we were talking about before I think
over the counter birth control is coming
I think that's I mean literally December
1968 like one of the very very first
issues of reason cover story is about
birth control so I recognize that it's a
little crazy to be like we're gonna
solve this now guys but but some other
stuff came true from those issues so you
never know and I think that the
combination of a Republican in power who
is encroaching on Obama cares mandate to
provide birth control is allowing more
and more exemptions to that which i
think is a good thing and the
realization that plan B the emergency
contraception being over-the-counter has
not in fact resulted in like just like
women's bodies scattered all over the
ground with their like ovaries dangling
out like it's gonna be fine everyone's
recognizing it's gonna be fine and even
though we are generally not moving the
direction of giving people more control
over their bodies in their own health
information
I do think birth control could be
liberated in some forms from the
pharmacist
what I mean what could reasonably expect
could reasonably expect C could mean but
it could mean like it's totally
reasonable and we should expect it and
then there's is it reasonably likely to
happen so like I let I cover mostly
federal policy the federal level like
nothing is actually nothing good is
actually likely however it is completely
a new dress food you wrote about net
neutrality six years ago does repeal
okay so I'm thinking of Congress here
but at the federal level it is
completely reasonable to expect Congress
to return to normal order when it comes
to the budgeting process they should do
it they have been out of they have not
been doing it for basically twenty years
now it has been breaking down since I
want to say the last time they passed
all of the appropriations bills
correctly according to according to
Hoyle like by September and had the
whole the whole shebang put together was
like right before you came back to the
United it was 97 and then there was
complete bruh
I mean a near complete breakdown under
Obama yeah I mean it got worse under
under George Bush and it was and it was
much worse than it totally broke down
under Obama and there's not really any
sign that it's going to come back you
have a couple of senators who sort of
gripe about it every now and then but it
could and it should it wouldn't be that
hard and we wouldn't end up in these
dumb situations like literally we are in
now in which it looks quite possible I
don't think it I don't want to say it's
likely but it certainly looks possible
that the combination of Democratic
anti-trump burrs and Senate GOP
muckety-mucks and Donald Trump could end
up shutting down the government on
December 7th because they can't agree to
give Trump the 5 billion dollars he
wants to build his stupid border wall
which was supposed to be paid for by
Mexico and those Mexicans Nick school
choice I think universal school choice
in the sense that parents or the the
idea that you should go to schools that
you are assigned to is breaking down
rapidly and as in many other parts of
our lives where we do have more autonomy
and choice I think the logic of just
saying you know what let's have schools
public schools charter schools mostly
kind of compete for students and I have
people sign up I think that's
accelerating and it you know within 5 to
10 years
I think that's low-hanging fruit that
will have a massive change on the way
that people get educated and it will
particularly help the lower income
people all right reason.com webathon
hello hi go so more questions here let's
throw this to Katherine is the current
brand manager here Joe clave from hit
and run do you see it as a victory when
Republican pundits and politicians why
she's got to be Republican dude pundits
politicians self-identify as libertarian
or libertarian on issue X or is it a
watering down / bastardization the
libertarianism yeah I don't know I used
to always say like anybody who wants a
label like you do that you
it come on in like the tent is huge
let's hang out at the party together the
rise of the alt right out of the ranks
of people who identified many of them as
libertarians has made me rethink that
somewhat this question is about sort of
mainstream Republican types who
identifies libertarian that I generally
like because I think lots of people
describe themselves as Republicans and
in fact even reason staffers just
because they didn't have another word
and if we can give them another word
that's like Republican but better then
yes they're welcome to it all right
Stephen Karen now from YouTube what is
the libertarian position on the public
notification of sex offenders what is
your personal opinion about the public
notification of sex offenders Peter
you're from Florida I mean we've done a
bunch of stuff that that's like a
non-count right on your birth
certificate you're put on a sex registry
I mean Lord a man might have some
additional connotations attached to it
and not even when you're naked in a
Waffle House perhaps like strangling a
chicken new in the morning euphemism
yeah yeah no look sexually the problem
with sex offender registries is that
they are often a far too far to broaden
who they cover they and they often end
up keeping people who have done who in
some cases have done something that is
really wrong would keep keep keeping
people who have done at most in some
cases just one thing that was quite
wrong and who have otherwise either sort
of paid for their crime end up keeping
those people out of out of a lot of
communities and unable in some cases
just to live anywhere in in cities and
like and this I think if this is a hard
thing to sell to say parents you know in
nice school districts in in nice
suburban communities but people who have
done one thing wrong and who have
changed and who are not likely to be who
have shown no signs that they are going
to be repeat offenders those people
deserve a chance to live normal lives
and this is just not a popular message
like people just don't want to be around
well in its
so I mean the fact is is that the
recidivism rate of sex offenders as a
group is not higher than it is for other
criminals and that was the idea
yes that has been for years for decades
and you know the idea of a sex offender
registry that these crimes are so
particularly awful and then a lot of the
times they turn out to be cases where it
might be a 17 year old with a 15 year
old in a consensual relationship that
dogs people for a long time
I think it's wrong and it's also I you
know it you don't have to have sympathy
for sex offenders to recognize the idea
when the government or when the state
and whatever level starts creating
permanent registries that they make
public this is not a good thing and we
are in many ways I think we're moving
out of the phase where people are done
with building more prisons and putting
more people in jail we're not done with
the idea of surveilling more people and
having people walk among us but then
subject to all sorts of different laws
and things like that and I think it's
worth you know I think sex offender
registries are wrong for all of the
reasons that Peter talked about plus the
fact that there's no indication that
they actually protect the public so I
mean it's just it's a useless a useless
added cost that creates more of a
service they weren't intended to protect
the public they were entirely a a
political scare tactic way harder it is
the idea of like when you buy a house
you know the realtor or the mortgage
company will say at some point like you
know you should here's the sex offender
registry go check out just to make sure
we're not going to do it for you et
cetera so I mean there is you know
there's the notion behind announced and
campaigned on B as a sort of way of
playing to a certain type of suburban
you know sort of safe School District
voter who who
it's very actually somewhat similar to
to the way that Donald Trump talked
about immigrants right it's not exactly
the same but there's a related kind of
it says it was a political care of it
yikes we have a comment here from Jay
wall hit-and-run
saying I've listened the podcast for a
couple of years you're doing it as a
hit-and-run Jay well but this is the
first time I've seen what you all look
like because this is a pictures are
really hard to find they're at
reason.com
uh I know I know because it's fun that's
why we all like each other and I'm
amazed to say that you are largely how I
imagined I know you didn't mean that as
a compliment but thank you because it
could have been a lot worse we're all on
our own brand brand day after day that's
just a reminder to everyone you can
subscribe to said podcast and listen new
year with your earholes
over there on Apple podcast and imagine
how I look
you can Ahmet you can spend that whole
podcast just imagining sudirman as a
Disney character in the Hall of
Presidents but also a Spotify word which
way time piracy the Carribean us I'm
it's a small but I mean yeah I don't
want to I'm making my black rum and you
know dip here in it have you been to the
Pirates of the Caribbean ride since they
cleaned it up because didn't by putting
Johnny Depp in it but no but the ride at
Disneyworld is Utley and they got rid of
the yeah the pillaging and all of that I
have not been since like 1995 for anti
pillaging okay I look forward to the
Robert Bly book about how we're losing
that innocence here we've got a trifecta
about climate change I'm actually going
to throw it out in a libertarian sense
to the panel here three questions they
can each take whatever one they want and
II favor says why the blind support for
the climate change narrative Gareth Cox
says what are some libertarian climate
change policies and Brent corner says
how will markets solve global warming
who wants what peace go
that's so good that's the whole spectrum
of questions actually that's that's kind
of great um the answer here and always
is Ron Bailey Ron Bailey is the answer
to why are we so credulous of this
so-called climate change because Ron
Bailey reads graphs for fun he eats
statistics for breakfast and he says
it's real and I for one trust Ron Bailey
in a way that
trust virtually no one else certainly
not the people at this table and Ron
Bailey also has some excellent answers
for questions two and three he is a
supporter of carbon taxes as the least
bad thing that might happen that people
might actually go for it is the least
inefficient way to price in some of the
negative externalities of human-produced
greenhouse gases also though there's all
kinds of cool technology out there that
might work to reduce global warming
without actually just making everybody
sit at home in the dark without even a
candle because that's what
environmentalists want us to do I'll
take a swing at the idea of like how
will free markets solve or stop climate
change they won't but what they will do
is they'll make it make us more
resilient and able to live with it the
fact is it's there there is climate
change I agree with Katherine and I I
thought Ron is my guru on all of this
stuff I don't doubt that there's you
know climate change increased
temperatures all of that kind of
variability of weather with the
possibility of a catastrophic event but
the real thing is not how do you stop
civilization and go back to some level
that may or may not have any effect on
it it's like how do you live with it and
you do that by getting richer and I
would also point out that there's this
thing called the Kuznetsov which is
originally observed outside the field of
environmental science but it's the
notion that as certain societies are as
all societies actually as the point it's
curved I get richer they get cleaner in
a way that is not widely observed even
at the time in the places that they're
getting cleaner because people are kind
of hardwired to believe that
everything's getting worse and in fact
weirdy carpeting a little bit in this
country I mean we're we're down to what
1990 levels now of greenhouse gas output
in this country people don't want to
hear that and and a lot of people who
are most alarmed about climate change
are the ones who are least happy to hear
that the biggest single reason for that
especially over the last five years is
the replacements of coal factories with
hydraulic fracturing and natural gas
because they're against hydraulic
fracturing for its own particular
reasons but
there was a know where Othman was on on
Morning Joe I think a couple of days ago
and just got a ton of heat and I saw
Twitter feed because he said basically
the same to same things that are I think
are true one is that most recent
projections for how things are going to
get worse over the next five to ten
years have all overshot how things
actually have gone even though we are
warmer every single year um that's true
and the other thing that he said is
basically what I just said which is that
getting richer helps you mitigate not
just the effects but the problem itself
um these are not non-answers these are
actual answers and when you want to talk
about okay do what are you willing to
trade are you willing to trade a point
of economic growth per year per century
for what in for your regulation we start
actually talking to people about what
the trade-off they're willing to have
that's a real conversation it's not a
fake one Peter in terms of I mean policy
responses you know I'd like run Bailey
favored a clean carbon tax one the
biggest problem with a clean oh but was
it right but with a simple
straightforward kind of not a lot of
exceptions built in this is the prop the
big problem with all the carbon tax
proposals is that they always get larded
up with kind of like carve outs and sort
of and non-standard exceptions
- right instead of just saying no again
stick alright and those yeah I think
everybody should be against the carbon
but here's the thing
but yes sink but our thing about the
carbon tax we should tax things that are
bad and we should and that should be
that and we should not tax other things
and so you can you can do a swap with
the payroll tax that is revenue neutral
so it doesn't grow the size of
government and what it does is it
disincentivizes bad behavior and lets
you take more money home and so I like
whenever I hear you sing this song I
want to sing along but it's it's like
the level of not gonna happen is so deep
they're like oh I know we'll just be
revenue-neutral it would have totally
four-carbon like I don't think you say
that I didn't say Congress was gonna
pass this I said this was what I would
favor a net in fact I explicitly
mentioned the carve-outs because the the
further away you get from a
straightforward clean carbon tax the
less effective and worthwhile apology
what is that
Claire Mullin what to make for dinner
but is it just can I ask what's it with
the whole idea behind the carbon tax is
that we can quantify the amount of
externality that a you know cubic ton or
whatever of carbon causes and so we tax
it at that rate to discourage it you
just guess maybe you're just making it I
know but then it's like why would why
you know and so you're trying to reduce
the amount of carbon that's being used
but then that money just goes to
whatever the government is gonna pay
there's a should let innovation go and
there's another policy that I actually
think it's already interesting which is
basically say we take no action at all
except we impose a small sort of growth
fee on the economy that says that a
small percentage of our growth over the
next hundred years we're gonna take that
money and we're gonna put it towards
specifically like we're gonna pay people
to try and figure out what to do and and
so we say like let's let the economy
grow as fast as it can and we will just
serve and we will just devote a small
percentage of the growth to to Japan and
like growth free and so it's a pro
growing fault process and I don't you
know again you can see that policy going
wrong but it also wouldn't be
catastrophic and wouldn't be too
expensive and then is Langley soon after
our loss we make some of the right
permits going wrong I'm just going to
ask this question because we've just
demonstrated an answer to it unless it's
been removed since the last time that I
was looking here we know what you all
this is from Chris card at YouTube we
know what you all at reason generally
agree on what do you generally disagree
on we're saying on carbon tax off we
disagree and this was a numbers that we
that's we didn't ask but taxation is
theft she's yes Nick is know what else
do we disagree I think there's my vs.
Robert Heinlein oh that's really saying
that Asimov has over Heinlein our side
burns let's vote terrible on every
available Heinlein it's a generation
blood
yeah even though weren't they basic to
the language let's keep going
Bryan Brady from email that 20th century
technology says what's a reduced not
reformed government guy to do the
Libertarian Party is so ideologically
pure is it right that it can't get
elected will elected Republicans are
increasingly crony capitalists and
elected Democrats are becoming
Stalinists I think you might be engaging
in some hyperbole Bryan but you pose
some interesting we do not do that here
we had no never never
that's not hyperbole itself I think
Justin Amash pretty much one of the only
good members of Congress had tweet just
today about basically the same thing
like it we're it's a legit question
though like what what are what what are
you gonna do when you're when you're we
want to try and make my answer to you is
go read your Hayek C so you can tell me
what's in it um but also that there
isn't a one true way man
I mean there's a you can you can talk
about there is no one true way nobody
knows the one true but you gotta like
you got to keep on keeping on and you
fight for a reduction in the size scope
and spending of government that's all
right but he's that's what he's saying
about vote you vote for people who say
that they're gonna reduce the size of
government
and beer because it's made in jessamine
washes I just did I think the answer
here is seasteading just want to throw
that out there that's a drink um get
that off I'm sure there's a crypto
question or blockchain questions I mean
I just but there's no there's so many
different ways of political engagement
road we were talking about earlier today
about Neil Gorsuch okay there's a small
libertarian win where did that come from
that came from a 3040 year process of
the libertarian legal movement going
from youth being to a much bigger to a
genuinely competitive elements within
the broader kind of center rights
tent out there as damon root has written
so wonderfully about including in this
book overruled so that's one way that
you affect social change that has kind
of nothing to do on some level with who
won last election depending on whatever
there's just so many different ways to
go about it that I think we we tend to
way over
thank or prioritize our approach towards
what we should vote for an election what
party we should root for or whatever
there's other ways we think of these
things as two and four year cycles
because that's when we vote and that's
totally understandable but real policy
change takes decades and you can look at
good and bad policy changes that have
happened basically certainly in my
lifetime I was born in 1981 and the big
policy movements on health care in in
particulars the one I know but as you
mentioned sort of the kind of rise of
the conservative legal conservative and
libertarian legal movement the federal
society all of these things are are
movements and ideas that took decades to
develop and to become to come to
fruition and to matter and there were
points along all of these along the
timeline where all of those kind of
looked like failures like they might not
work like they were just gonna get
overtaken by whatever stupid thing was
on the front page of the news or CNN
that day but because people stuck with
it and sort of believed in the long game
and so this to me if you want to make
real big you know a big long term impact
in politics you have to play a long game
you have to assume that you that you are
going to look like you are failing a lot
of the way along the way until you get
there this is also true of many
libertarians and every now and then like
I don't know it turns out Bitcoin made
money or what else yes there's a new
churin magic after all that's the other
part of it is that is that if you're a
libertarian you not only can but you
should believe that a lot of political
change come comes from unexpected parts
of places that are not in politics and
you can look at Bitcoin or you can you
know if Elon Musk I I will say that I am
skeptical that this happens but if Elon
Musk sends a bunch of people to Mars
that will not be primarily because
somebody in Congress or even because an
activist group here you know the send it
send Americans to Mars pack decided I
should do Jerome Corsi
nice Crescent totally got a died it
wasn't their book about how
to affect political yeah I think so
let's go lighting around quick here
Catherine Claire Mullin from Facebook
our friend Claire asks what should I
make for dinner tonight good excellent
question my answer for you is kangaroo
Oh an underrated meat super delicious
they're basically pests so it's if
anything averts you to kill them
marinate it with the something acidic
and then serve it with some fig
delicious and you should start your
dinner with a mezcal Negroni yes Scott
Miller from facebook asks a pointed
question Peter tacks things that are bad
who makes that decision I mean not to
say if we're gonna tax anything which we
shouldn't because we have to have a
government and that government we so to
go back to what we disagree on Peters
the libertarian who thinks that maybe we
have to have a government Andy let's say
let's let's forget that I'm not even
sure I have opinion about whether we
have to have one we do and we are going
to we can agree on and so since we have
a government and since we would rather
it not just kind of collapse tomorrow or
at least I would rather it not just sort
of collapse into chaos tomorrow like
we're going to shut it down it should be
orderly and planned which haha just like
we are currently running creates that
but like so the government is going to
decide this but we get to elect the
government we get to influence them and
in fact it taxes are one place where
voters have a huge amount of influence
and have been and American voters have
been quite successful at limiting tax
hikes in some ways and not limiting
spending increases but American voters
have been quite successful relative to
their European democratic counterparts
at limiting tax hikes and so it's a
place where voters have a lot of
influence axes should be recognized
first and fully as the revenue necessary
to pay for government they should not be
and this is one of the reasons I'm
against a carbon tax is for the same
reason I'm against a tobacco tax and you
know I realize there are externalities
but it's like no taxes should be value
free as much as possible and they should
be based on consumption rather than on
income or anything else well carbon tax
does end up taxing consumption - so yes
I think all of us all of us maybe I'm
wrong maybe Katherine is so against
taxes that she wouldn't prefer better
taxes I would better taxes but like all
of us would agree on the consumption
part which you know that we should
probably not have we should either
radically lower or not have an income
tax at all and we should be taxing
consumption we should probably do things
through a value-added tax which is
harder to cheat is a better which is a
just a pure consumption donates a reason
where we're gonna advocate for carbon
taxes and the dat holy crap I think I
think we have a the ability to entities
Mike more lightning around questions
here nicholas bjs economics from youtube
julian assange
friend-or-foe of freedoms i think Julian
Assange to date has been very good for
freedom I think that I traversal I think
that WikiLeaks has been a force for good
by exposing horrible government actions
and I think it continues to be that I
don't care I don't know anything about
Julian Assange as a person nor do I care
to I'm thinking that his you know little
cubbyhole at the Ecuadorian Embassy
probably is smells worse than like any
you know high college seniors dorm room
ever could but WikiLeaks has been great
for forced transparency and more power
to them and and just very quickly you
know the idea that Assange or WikiLeaks
is doing Russia's bidding by exposing
bad things that the American government
or actors in the American government
it's done there might be some
plausibility or some truth to that I
don't care because what I want to know
about is what my government is doing and
when it's when it's doing bad things the
oh and one other thing is that some of
the stuff that WikiLeaks released at
various points it should diplomatic
communications among America where we
were actually pretty we were saying the
same thing in private and in public in
our diplomacy in a way that many other
countries weren't we actually I mean
WikiLeaks has has been a very very
important and powerful force for good
Shaun Andrew from YouTube asks new media
enables
more and more niche celebrities can the
team comment on this phenomenon depends
on if I still get scrolled down by our
staffer and their own celebrity Rhian
status and the weirdness this begets all
the answer this instead of a team but
there's the words libertarian is not a
thing it's not a thing it's it's a word
that people use the thing that it
describes is not a thing that's good
enough okay how let's see
Kyle Lolo from Facebook thoughts on the
crypto currency markets current slide
Kryptos long-term impact on our society
and how close the crypto anarchist
strain of crypto fits with libertarian
ideals Kathryn once you take that since
you're the anarchist though it's I am
optimistic about blockchain though not
super optimistic about crypto currency
as currency in the immediate future
it fits wonderfully with all of the
anarchism that we got hanging around
here and and in fact is probably the
most exciting development in anarchism
in my lifetime as if that's a sentence
anyone cares about yeah that's my answer
I think I think the idea of distributed
Ledger's is impossible to explain and
that well still doesn't understand them
but that it will be one of these things
like the internet where people don't
have to understand it when it just worms
its way into their lives and governs
everything they do in a way that is less
controllable by the state we will all be
better off I think that crypto
philosophy is great and there was
actually a pretty good New Yorker
feature on some of the the guys who were
involved in this and sort of explaining
that they just ran maybe a month or two
and kind of laying out a case that that
for these folks some of them have become
exceptionally well off because of
Bitcoin but they're not really there
it's it's not just about the money or
it's in some cases maybe not even
primarily about the money it's about the
idea which is to create a system where
two people who don't know each other or
a thousand people who don't know each
other can
have a transaction between them that
they could that they and everyone else
involved everyone else in the world who
is involved in the system can trust and
think that you can do it without the
government or without any centralized
overseer and that is an incredibly
powerful idea that bitcoin is making
happen all the time and I think that
idea is going I actually think that that
idea really will change the world
over the next decades can I say also
really fast one great thing about
Bitcoin is that since it is totally
distributed there's no one person in
charge of it
who can screw it up for everyone else by
being a douche bag which I think lots of
exciting technological developments have
the petrushka douche bag in charge
problem maybe even Reason magazine might
have the don't think of it as a problem
yeah and by nobody the glumpers can call
our chains do not have a douche bag in
charge and they don't have anything that
anyone can boycott or call and complain
or whatever and that is certainly needed
okay Rob Simmons has a question Facebook
I'll direct this one towards Nicolas
Gillespie I support the legalization of
marijuana he writes although I do too I
also oppose federal marijuana laws but I
also defended Jeff Sessions when he said
he would enforce those federal laws I do
not think it is in our best interest to
have elected officials enforcing only
those laws they agree with what is your
view of the concept of rule of law you
know Rob shipments who runs Stossel in
the classroom he's a friend and an ally
in many aspects I agree you don't want
necessarily you don't want elected
officials who only enforce the laws they
believe in by the same token when drug
laws or when laws are bad they should
not be followed and people should be
kicked out of office if if enough people
agree with them you also have to
prioritize the federal government has so
many comps they don't have enough people
to enforce the recreational use of
marijuana they just don't there's not
got a body count problem and so you can
ask the federal government to have
prioritization issues with it regardless
of rule of law but this is uh sort of
bad I'll cite one of our
favorite authors bill James who is
talking about whether or not it's legal
to block to plate by catchers or other
fielder's in baseball you shouldn't it's
also true you shouldn't have laws that
do not actually carry though either the
popular will or should be laws in the
first place and we should be trying to
get rid of that don't reflect reality
yeah en route from YouTube people just
like make it phonetic or to invent a new
one how to win a fight with a Bernie
Sanders supporter do I just walk away
just be nice be a nice person you're not
gonna win on the merits nobody wins
fights by giving an argument that
changes someone's mind in the moment
what you want to do is show that you're
a person of goodwill and that you
believe they are people of goodwill and
then you want to just like in cept
whatever idea you think they're the most
vulnerable to and then you just want to
be like change the subject walk away I
really believe that I really believe in
in-person conversation that is the only
way to go like no one has ever
browbeaten anyone into submission in a
conversation and had them so my parents
and become a libertarian I agree and
also you know one of the first things is
to establish like what do what are you
arguing about are you arguing about it
you should do that by saying we need to
define some terms yeah but I you know I
find this is true of a lot of
conservatives as well as progressives or
whatever where they're angry about
something but then like you know is it a
question of like are we trying to help
the poor are we trying to make the
environment cleaner are we trying more
options that's my land then be like are
we yeah we you know are we arguing about
ends or are we arguing about means and
in some cases like you you get pretty
quickly where it's like no I don't think
people should have these choices you
know to live this way or to do this or
to do that and that's what your lighting
how's about those bill James's and the
baseballs yeah that's good that was that
good tonight good attempt a question for
Peter David Burns from you to see that
good phonetic name day brevis I your
name this right frankly like maybe
generation a stand also like racist
you only want white dude names old white
dude names
Dave is Dave doesn't see color that's I
mean again it's just my own name
this pardon this question may be best
suited for Peter because certain people
disabled will not understand what
language you're speaking but what are
your thoughts on the FTC investigating
the use of loot boxes in video games my
thoughts are that loot boxes are
terrible and the FTC shouldn't worry
about them at all the FCC has many many
many many many other things to
investigate and in fact like fraud is
like a legitimate area for the
government to like to to be like focused
on and and prevent butlet but loot boxes
aren't fraud they advertise that it is
that is a system to basically hold with
you in video games with in video games
there are randomized rewards and it's
like a slot machine and so and jump
right in in the way in the way that when
you sit at a slot machine and drop in
your nickels or your quarters or your
dollars or whatever and you pull and
it's just totally randomized based on an
algorithm it's not that you your dough
you just play until you accidentally win
and that's what video games now do in
many cases but actually what I what I
would say is that if you look at the
last year there has been a huge player
revolt against loot boxes players are
saying these games suck I know it we
don't want to play these games we are
not going to buy them and in several
cases the developers have actually
backed down either removing or limiting
the limiting what how loot boxes affect
the play and so the FTC doesn't need to
because you know what gamers themselves
figured out how to get game developers
to stop making loot boxes that are
terrible and ruin your games loot box
this question from Ed Moser from YouTube
I'll take it to next it's fun it's this
is one of the potential Aleppo question
if it works out where well name of five
countries you'd withdraw US troops from
go five countries I Aussies already
there are that many no but I mean first
off I would start with Korea had Syria
Iraq Iran well not Iran but
bases in Saudi Arabia Canada the US had
a Canada yeah I think so and I don't
know am i up to five yet I think it's
pretty close Germany do we need no
medical the medical facilities in in
Germany
he's just in port Sherman II and my wars
that we're conducting United States
border zone nice I'll have you know that
when I wrote the the weather box at the
UC Santa Barbara Daly Nexus newspaper we
put a little slogan underneath the staff
box so that would change every day and
it was supposed to be comical it's a
Cold War
you're a joke Nick um I put at the
bottom as a slogan one day a u.s. out of
Nebraska and then that's still funny
that is still that's you are the dad
joke life right it is speaking of which
if you haven't rewatched the libertarian
dad jokes video from reason TV from the
Bragg brothers and andrew heaton uh hey
Matt do make any videos like that does
that cost money that costs money cost a
lot of money yeah for andrew heaton to
stand in front of a green screen and say
really funny things by which i mean
super funny um and that's what we're
here we're doing webathon here we
started this this broadcast good seventy
five minutes ago a very good seventy
five minutes ago when you had two
hundred and you know for being honest so
it feels longer yeah it does but so go
to reason calm slash webathon get in
there there's all kinds of giving levels
you get swag you get stuff you get to
like you we have a scroll the top of the
reason calm the hit and run page that
says this gift comes from you know fists
of etiquette just throw name out there
and then they have a little space to
like talk smack to write one name
associate so let's start asking the
important questions
this one from dr. armageddon it at
twitter aside from hash tag or at Matt
Welch sorry do any of you play musical
instruments and he goes ahead and
Imagineers this one I can imagine K
manga Ward playing the piccolo suit Minh
playing the keyboard okay so I
I did play the piccolo yes so
congratulations to you sir or ma'am wait
with a big band head on yep I sure did I
played the flute and the piccolo and I
was the drum major of my high school
marching band so that's everything you
need to know about me right there and
but Peters answer to this is even better
than mine but I before he answers I do
just want to say we have discussed here
in the office we could do like a pretty
decent we could field a pretty decent
pep band like if anybody has any
sporting of an Tina band it'd be like a
Star Wars clean the Star Wars it's my
battle yeah
go ahead Peter what did you play so I
played the sousaphone 47 years Ronin
tuba also played a little bit of flute
an awful lot of guitar and bass and I
what kind of band in my well wait wait
that's several different kinds I was
never in a ska band with I was never
once in a ska band with any instruments
I was or Eddie I was never in a ska band
period of any kind I'd feel like you
were I knew people in ska bands I went
to their shows but no I was never in
it's kind of lame I played the tuba in
the sousaphone how do you get in how are
you like I want to play the sousaphone
so I can tell you exactly is you go
sabri's you go to them the Ruckle middle
school band rudiment fair over the
summer between fifth and sixth grade
when you're about to enter middle school
when the van program is about to start
and you go there during one of the
several open house days and they just
basically shove a bunch of instruments
like up to you you're like your Dali
Lama or do you kind of try them and like
and like one of them feels right and you
just know it crappy thinking about the
sousaphone is great because the
sousaphone darts the eye and script Ohio
and that oh yeah they're marching band
no that's of the Martians like watch it
marching band instruments that is the
yeah you of course you want to play the
sousaphone yeah I mean the the amazing
triangle the sousaphones and the drums
are sort of the backbone
marching band I actually did not like
marching season a really punch preferred
concert season I just like that we're
not even thinking about Nick Gillespie
answering no no I have no musical
ability well you should tell us about
your it's not interesting so how genes
atoms actually your musical instrument
it is a little relevant because you were
a busker right sure talking about it so
why don't you continue guitar that I
could bring you wrote now so James Adams
off from YouTube says if you had to
choose one libertarian book to convince
non libertarians what would it be odds
are first man I'm not about convincing
other people Kathryn you go what that's
a terrible answer you work for an
opinion magazines where it is that I
need to be a broken record but like I
still think yeah well are we talking
bout a teenager or grown-ass person okay
teenager were definitely anything in the
sort of utopian world breaking science
fiction zone is gonna be good like your
Heinlein's your rands whatever for
grown-ups though I actually would go
with with my other cliche answer here
which is some Steven Pinker um I
actually will answer the question
because I think about it this has worked
over even despite a lack of intention on
some levels but I've recommended to many
people kindly inquisitors but Jonathan
Roush the great free speech book from 20
years ago but these are not neither
Pinker nor brash or hardcore libertarian
correct you don't mean like you know
what convince people who are really not
live if I'm trying to convince an on
liberties the question the question is
if you had to choose one libertarian
book to convince non libertarians what
would it be
okay yet you know if you had to choose a
question to depend about I'm saying for
these policies being wrong about
approving drugs what would it be would
be that Matthew McConaughey books or a
movie which is not made by a Peter wild
knickers oh I mean the moon is a harsh
mistress for you know anybody under 18
or
impossibly even people who over 18
depending on what they're like but I if
they're gonna pick a non-fiction book
probably capitalism and freedom which is
in some ways maybe not the greatest book
at convincing somebody who's already
decided that they are definitely not a
libertarian on the other hand is one of
the greatest elucidation of the ideas
and principles of kind of a free-market
and libertarian thinking that's ever
been said no the clarity of that book is
really just incredible
Peter not Peter you know what I'll throw
David boses libertarianism primer which
was reissued 20 years later as I think
the libertarian mind I think it's a good
eye kind of overview that is modern and
and complicated and sophisticated we're
gonna try to go as fast as possible we
have I think about ten minutes a more
scheduled here or that we're physically
we'll able to do here I will start with
the answer to this question from Travis
pellham Boozer on Facebook what's the
over-under on Bill well to 2020 the over
is that he will run for sure I predict
if there's no other super prominent
person who announces that he's
interested and whose name rhymes with
flushed and and next question here for
I'll do it for Catherine Abigail
Devereaux from Facebook what do you
folks think of Chinese creepy social
credit system that reduces all personal
commercial political behaviors to a
single number do you have anything to
say about that Catherine I have so many
things to say about that but this is a
fast round so I'm gonna just very
quickly say I have read a lot of science
fiction that suggests that actually some
sort of social karma social credit score
would actually be great awesome way to
live in the future and I am NOT ready to
abandon that vision but as always if you
take a good idea and you put it in the
hands of an authoritarian regime that
values the wrong things you will get a
horrible distorted outcome that results
in the deprivation of civil liberties
which is what we will see in China it's
pretty well done I send this one to Nick
from David Caddick on Twitter will it be
more important to support libertarian
presidential candidates into
20 compared to strategic voting to
remove Trump from office and they used a
small L and libertarian cases yeah I
think you should always vote your
conscience I don't really believe in
strategic voting in that sense so I'm
all I can say is I'm gonna vote for the
person who's the most libertarian in
2020 assuming I go Logan Hill from
Twitter ask and I'll direct it to Peter
what are some winning issues for the
libertarian movement that could propel
them to better success if they focused
on it national drug legalization and but
no no but like but in particular a kind
of a kind of mushy technocratic
middle-of-the-road centrist pot
legalization along the lines of what
Jonathan Roush suggests wrote and wrote
about in our 50th issue where he
basically says you know the way we that
the pot legalization and gay marriage
movements have been won so far is in
some ways by talking like a statist by
emphasizing tax revenue and legality and
normal you know and normalcy and I think
that to win this issue at the federal
level we're gonna have to sort of like
those of us who maybe don't want to see
this as sort of just become like a giant
tax scheme are gonna have to accept some
level of that as like a productive as
being much better than the current
regime and so I think that if the lp
sort of dialed with us or if lowercase L
libertarians dialed back a little bit
just a little every now and then about
what they'd sort of the range of
outcomes that they might be willing to
accept and said look let's do this
because it is because the country has
changed people now understand like the
public is now there
majority of Republicans I believe now
favor pot legalization this is a winning
issue it's low-hanging fruit for
everyone in any party we should be doing
it at the federal level immediately
michael Fiorelli on twitter asks a
question that I'll throw to Kathryn does
the second amendment make cops more
trigger-happy because they can plausibly
assume people are armed that's a good
question that is a good question um
probably overall it is fair to say the
existence and robustness of the Second
Amendment leads to more
more deaths at the hands of law
enforcement on the other hand there is I
think a pretty well-documented pattern
of cops using that as a rationalization
after the fact and not necessarily not
necessarily good evidence about what
they believed in the moment you know
people say I thought he had a gun after
they shoot someone that's what they say
we have no idea really what they thought
and and one thing that uniform cams and
dash cams have shown is that it's very
rarely the case that anyone's narrative
of the lead-up to a shooting is accurate
to the reality so so I guess I would
just say we shouldn't let cops get away
with shooting people because they say
the person had a gun and I'm somewhat
skeptical that that is always the
motivation a spotter
Eitan hit-and-run says we all need
Peters mug I presume he means his drink
receptacle where can we get it
unfortunately that is not for sale that
is a prototype mug when we relaunch the
website which we hope to do shortly with
the help of your webathon dollars
because making a website ain't free we
will also be relaunching our swag store
and if you are very good little boys and
girls we might let you buy sex drugs and
robots it's a good mug this one is going
to be for all of us I suppose from
Norman T Hester t'en then we could use
this as a possible bounce out here I
thank you all for watching all the way
through on YouTube Facebook and wherever
else that you're following us on audio
devices as well what is the best reason
to give to reason today Peter because we
need to have these mugs made a mess
produced and have been available for all
of our readers listeners lovers and
haters about merchandise for you know
it's not about merch
you know we're your voice in public
debates about politics culture and ideas
from a principled libertarian
perspective and if you like what we're
saying and if you want to us to get
better and have better arguments that
you can share with your friends that you
can share with your policymakers etc we
need your money it helps it's the
difference between us doing what we're
doing and
not doing what we're doing so if you
think libertarianism if you think reason
style reasons vision of the world and of
the future of expanding individual
liberty and individual autonomy is a
good thing that's what your money is
going to fund it costs money to do what
we do and you know this is something
that I think other charities other
things you can give your money to they
they often just make an appeal to need
they say listen we're doing what we're
doing is important and it cost money and
I think journalists are a little bit
loath to do that but in this case we
really should because you know this like
your donations are the difference
between can we put Elizabeth Knoll and
brown on a plane and fly her out to
Arizona to go hang out with the founders
of Backpage who are currently under
house arrest or pretty close to it and
talk about their story exclusively with
her your money is the difference between
whether we bring andrew heaton in here
and put a fur hat on him to do something
ridiculous your money of funds Peter
sermons very important cocktail
journalism and you know your money also
funds things that take a long time good
journalism takes a long time you put in
a FOIA request and then you lay down to
sleep for a hundred years and if your
CGC ramela you do this every single day
every single day you put it in you just
go out to the the winds and you say like
I hope I get a reply it takes time and
resources to do these kinds of things we
are getting information that no one else
is getting because we're looking in
places that no one else is looking and
you should give us your dollars to do
that I would add to all of that which is
true and more so last year I think
through our entire webathon exercise we
raised three hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars there's an incredible
amount of money they shattered previous
records we can't like 25 22 year olds
for that I get a lot of 22 year olds for
that and and as importantly I think it
came from more than a thousand
individual donors this many people
already subscribe to the magazine or
they don't or whatever and it's just ten
bucks here it's it's 15 20 bucks here
you don't understand how resilient that
makes us think about it for a second how
many magazines out there it could be a
website but generally speaking of
magazine a weekly standard
review a nation Mother Jones would it be
totally normal to have the last 20 years
worth of editors-in-chief sitting at a
table not forking each other's eyes out
or you know having a huge kind of a
split or a chasm between the overall
train and the through line of the
editorial product stop talking about my
metaphors it's not right it's there's
something special about that and even
even kind of sacred about that I can't
think of very many magazines that have
lasted for this long that it is
identifiable you can always see though I
mean there are moments when you know
Jack wheelers going crazy in 1983 sure
there's there's enthusiasms and temporal
temporal changes here and there but it's
always been from 1968 on from the
premier issue on it has been coherence
not contradictions in the words of a
lania Friedlander and part of that of an
integral part of that is the way the
people are attached to it fundamentally
they donate again just ten bucks they
subscribe just a little bit here but all
that creates this sort of mesh that
allows it to continue and not be at the
whims of a single moment a single
financial crisis a single whatever so
donate to make that happen and make
Katherine be better at what she does
and make Katherine junior even better
than Katherine can ever imagine before
it's all about Katherine junior that's
Sallu so troubling who's gonna have
crisper edited purple hair by the way is
there a movement to have women be able
to have you know like junior the third
that kind of maybe that's five years
wait was that a question from YouTube or
from Twitter when I clone myself what
women are waiting for actual cloning to
name named progeny after ourselves
I should we close with this do we want
to do a quick little four-part harmony
thing or any do we have any other it's
it was worth it oh 90 minutes is worth
it for that look alone go to in closing
go to reason calm webathon all the
giving
they're super easy just go click on
stuff give it all thanks for watching
thanks for all the comments we couldn't
come anywhere close to answering all of
these questions and we love them it's
another thing that we can do that maybe
not everybody else gets to do which is
actually interact with the people who
make our work possible so thank you for
all of it thanks again and keep on
looking out at the recent calm space and
hitting run for other fun webathon stuff
over the next four or five days and for
now we are out of here goodbye
[Music]